how's it going sweethearts but it's bad
welcome back to the wolf among us
episode 2 episode 2 Jesus no episode 3
episode [ __ ] it I don't even know so we
got a live look through cranes [ __ ]
hopefully we can find a clue uh I was
gonna rhyme something with shampoo and I
realized how lame that was alright let's
hear a lot of stuff the key seems to be
the best thing to check so use it it's
for the motel into his room at the open
arms yeah you still haven't told me what
was in there I don't think you want to
know exactly no I need to know
crane was uh pain lily to live out a
fantasy of him and you together I can
say that much right I'd give me if I
spare you the detailing moments in my
head
interactions with him when he'd catch me
in the elevator or bump into me outside
there's only so much you can repress you
know
you can have known what else is there
we'll get it worries know we'll get him
so come on let's keep looking
yeah uh yeah it could not be it doesn't
necessarily have to be crane it could be
someone looking like em or whatever
glamour like him that's what it's called
he barely told them what the hell yeah
all right well let's check this little
buck the office business oh oh I saw
Vikings page here that was torn out oh
yeah
which include Baskin do you know what
was here thank you
sorry what did you realize or at least
every magical item not retained in the
armory is assigned to someone in
Fabletown
it must be this which he is going to see
hmm wait what what which what meeting he
called up somebody he said he needed to
see his witch or that he would need to
get to the witch for that I think he met
his [ __ ] well yes it sounded like the
one he got his uh you Glamour's from I'm
sure it's about this ring they must have
it why not mention this before yeah
no one asked me muskan
and I'm hungover I'm sorry ah
he set the meeting at 2:00 a.m. tonight
what's going on is the mirror fixed yet
Bluebeard this isn't the time is the
mirror fixed or isn't it
you called me told just to see if you
knew where crane could be and that was
it okay and I'm sorry I said anything
more than that well you did and I know
the cats out of the bag so can we find
the doll pervert or not I tried to isn't
your concern I don't know why snow told
papa guiding hand crane talk all the
time okay he was a resource albeit one
that turned out to be useless we hardly
talked on ball time
besides why spend time I'm such
guttersnipe how is he jabbering a mouse
isn't the time he took a piece of the
mirror so we can't use it the only thing
we know is that cranes going to see a
widget two o'clock which is a pretty
good meal so why am y listen Bluebeard
you're not a part of this I don't think
you're in any position to turn away help
define help what do you know about I'm
gonna know what he knows so he can tell
us that he has the stones to kill
prostitutes like any common sex
frightened serial killer and not face a
real challenge
hey you're the bald one look we know
that crane is going to see a witch and
it's to acquire a magic ring what's the
ring we don't know what it does or who
it's assigned to since crane towards
page out of the book this Faust was your
ridiculous idea for a plan who put you
in charge in the first fixing the mirror
was the most logical Russian secretary
he's a sheriff and none of you were
chosen to run this office who elected
you to make these decisions nobody who
elected her to spin my body well I've
been doing that unofficially for years
I'm heading up the investigation okay
Bluebeard that makes this a moot point
and somebody needs to run the business
office while he does so wealthy excuse
me for having the Commonwealth in mind
and being ball
alright let's just look on the bright
side we know crane is going to see the
witch that's been supplying him
black-market Glamour's thanks to me and
that he'll be there at 2:00 so that
gives us how long short hours to find
out who it is and where they live and
get them all at once mmm a few short
hours the more you babble about it
tell me well yeah there's point in the
direction you want me to check first
since Lily used the Glamour's she'd have
known who the witch was and I don't
think Holly's burned her things yet it
would probably have the address or a
phone number or something and Big B is
free to go there if he likes but I think
the question you should be asking is
just what to the to Tweedles know about
that yeah it doesn't matter what they
know after tonight they never go to
their office they're not smart enough to
try go anywhere else
trip-trap is the better option to track
the witch down look chances are I'll
have to swing by both anyways no chances
are you won't have time I don't really
care what you two do I'm going to his
apart what you can't just go up there
and why do I not we already looked for
the key remember I don't know where it
is then I'll pick the blasted lock I've
wasted enough time waiting for the
mirror to find him I won't waste any
more you just can't go up there alone
alright
why not interested in nicking his drapes
my dear if that's what concerns you what
concerns me is you traipsing through
possible evidence oh now it's evidence
before you had no interest and now it's
a crime scene Bluebeard you're not going
he's being a [ __ ] I'm taking the boss
and what you gotta stand here and
babysit me well the rest of your leads
evaporated too missed we have to find
the witch Bluebeard since that's where
he's going or the sniveling weasel
chickened out never win anywhere and is
upstairs right now in his pitiful
penthouse crafting a fort out of couch
Coosh sounds fun I say that is how a
smart person would do it so this is how
we are going to do it wherever you go
I'll go to the other I don't like you
going anywhere unsupervised he's up to
something I don't know what it is but we
don't have the time to really worry
about it now how did he not hear that
yes he [ __ ] deaf if he did oh Jesus
Christ I'm gonna have to make a decision
okay I I think it makes sense since
we're two people and we have to [ __ ]
make decisions Jesus Christ don't make
it hard for me I got even a time is
ticking you praying alone and we leave
you alone I'd love to join you but
there's some business I need to attend
to
no no I'm better off dealing with things
alone
I don't need sympathy and I don't need
chair what [ __ ]
so here's okay I'm gonna do that Holly
feels like the thing you would pick
because you don't know you're on drugs
or some [ __ ] you don't know what's going
on I don't know why you would pick Holly
whatever holy a guy cooking up all that
liveth at D we already interrogated and
it led to nothing he's annoying I think
his mouth I just wanted to like take its
face and make a little ball out of it
maybe squeeze it in little in and like
rub it in my I don't know it's I'm weird
but I think we should just go to cranes
places yeah here I should check that out
first perfect and I'll go to those two
imbeciles office Yankee was those
penthouse numbers 1903 let me know what
you find
I hope you know what you're doing oh god
I don't remember the name I was in
nineteen uh what big eyes you have
hahahaha where is that from now again
yeah it's around the big round that
little red riding hurting whatever
isn't it yeah alright so we go into
cranes apartment he's probably not gonna
be here but that isn't stopping from
dancing um oh god it was not that room
Oh God
uh well that's the door open I bet he's
gonna be naked on the bed anyone in
there I've waited funny a big B rain
maybe we'll find a murderer or some
weird [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we have a timer that
stresses me out I don't like that does
he have a statue by himself
no that dick hole must have missed him
gotta be something about his which here
don't know why they keep calling him my
era which that's the father are you
doing here Headless Horseman
i wouldI have that or it unlocks an
entry desk examine teacher examine
answering machine that would make sense
it does have blinky Blucher crane look
that crooked man isn't happy compadre as
much as I like making house calls
I have better ways to use my time so you
can go ahead and make it by Friday that
would be great
alright everybody can stay upright in
the meantime leave the light on now see
ya I must have been his [ __ ] this
hasn't been used in years and why am I
looking through it
Merry Christmas mr. crane thanks for all
the help this year since the early Jerry
Baker huh he used to teach in the old
days what a nerd okay what did we got
here I can't click honey hmm
Wow this is a ladder why didn't I check
that who has a [ __ ] painting a
Crooked Man
Oh Edith yet I'm afraid snow start to
notice I'll have the rest for you next
week Nick about oh what's going on here
yeah Comfort yep I guess I got it
confiscated in case it and top in
someone else's hey I'm hungry
my dearest snow I know you must be aware
of my feelings towards you
I'm watching you work I'm unable to
control myself it's because I love you
did he really write that huh
I'd be useful in my by hahahahahaha same
brand we found in the open arms it's not
really a clue is it so let's get out
let's check can we go out no we can't
can we check the books picture I've
never seen him that excited guess things
have changed yeah he's always so [ __ ]
grumpy yeah science history I did guess
Joey oh [ __ ] didn't work hahahaha was
that the washer was it the door god damn
swaggy
it's a nice flight it's not too shabby I
wouldn't mind a few pictures of myself
and a statue maybe like a water slide to
the kitchen so I don't have to move if
I'm in the bed I'd be nice okay
oh I used to kill you cuz I'm smart
don't need to use my fists that's right
baby
you heard it hallo die stay where you
are
what I up jack wow it is just
unbelievable running into you here
I mean of all the places we're gonna
fight weather right here'll a little
damp I guess but you know some people
like that sort of thing explain yourself
now okay okay okay I know what it looks
like but before you go jump into
conclusions crane pays me to water his
plant whinnies go it's a stipend but you
know I need the work I wouldn't do it
for free right you know me
so anyways uh now that I'm done I don't
see any plans Hey
really EXR set that light gray you got
me
just take it easy this is really [ __ ]
necessary now you try to [ __ ] run
okay okay
I heard crane was leaving town I figured
he owed us little people a parting gift
or just me a parting gift you heard I
have my sources
okay how does everyone keep finding
lives he doesn't need any of this [ __ ] a
little Robin hooding never hurt anyone
right do you know where crane is have
you heard anything else about it no
should I have
what else do you want me to say I got
bills to pay
not like cranes gonna use any of this
stuff so don't you know hit me again
did somebody send you tell the truth
it's fine no it's just me just take it
easy okay fine oh yeah can I can't hug
ya I gotta for God I just had him one
this tortured lonely piggy herb it's
gonna get old eventually don't you get
tired of it
I mean what are you even doing here what
do you think are you just wandering
around cranes apartment
what's a point I'm investigating it
doesn't have to know what I'm doing well
looks like you've got it covered anyway
it was really nice catching up with you
I mean that
are they gonna make out he be I believe
you're up blocking the doorway there if
I could just squeeze through it looks
like that we're gonna be great on second
thought it's actually funny I ran into
you like this
I think I can help you out oh here we go
I'm listening go on I'm listening you're
looking for crane right well I don't
know where he is but what if I told you
I know who might know where he is uh-huh
Street says he's got a witch in the city
bingo I can tell you who she is if
you're interested information comes at a
price though but I'm sure you already
knew no we're not gonna tell me let's
make ourselves a deal I tell you about
cranes witch and you forget you saw me
here one hand washes the other sort of
thing what if we the whole incident
under the one come on we're not supposed
to punch him so I'm gonna say deal and
we can give him the money that I stole
from crane tell me where I can find my
strong grip her name is auntie Greenland
cranes been trying to keep it under
wraps for years if you're looking for
crane she might know how to find him so
wanna make sure he doesn't [ __ ]
why didn't I click it's so [ __ ] fast
the thing is I don't know where you'd
find her exactly you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me
but even a name is a good start right I
mean that's more than what you came in
with I can't damn optimist right I'll
keep my eyes open if I find anything
else you might be interested in I'll be
sure to let you know I got a I think
this arrangement can be beneficial to
both of us down the line
I don't like this man ah oh god he's
gonna just lovely running into you baby
hang on a second yeah come on you could
have been there to steal evidence or
whatever I'm just saying I got a see
suggest I wanna come out it makes me
yeah whatever glad oh the white deer do
you always talk to yourself like that
yes No yeah which uses the white deer on
everything it's her symbol or trademark
I guess oh that's a good info I could
sell these at the Lucky pawn the lucky
pawn it's one of the crooked man's
places I worked there sometimes when I
need some stability get a haircut next
time Jase it's a pawn shop get it yeah
yeah you find any more at least no
give them Julie what you know what hand
them over
yeah big me ah are you still here we're
in here snow we who else is he's gone
what's he doing here Oh evening miss
white good evening
what's going on that's not important
yeah now we think that he did have some
information about cranes which Oh what
did you find out her name is green
auntie Greenleaf but he doesn't know
where we can find her
great cranes meeting her at toy em and
snow I found a note with some money
attached Green has been embezzling from
Fabletown of course because why
half-assed being a complete sleaze ha ha
ha ha ha murders I mean I guess it
doesn't matter yet we still have to find
him yeah snatching Hearst we don't care
I just want to get the [ __ ] guy
cranes meeting Greenleaf at 2:00 a.m.
and we have no idea where she is
we're going to cut it close as it is we
have to figure out where he's meeting
her I'll figure it out
cuz I'm handsomest [ __ ] you should try
Holly's she still has all of Lily's
things she hasn't burned it already
there's still Tweedledee Spice
we know they're involved and we know
that's where Bluebeard went where do you
want to go we don't have much time Jesus
Christ more decisions I don't know how
to make you stations okay all right this
is calm down and then XF is that all
right leave a comment what do you think
we should go next and I'll listen to you
the majority will speak and you can't
hold it against me
democracy [ __ ] all right leave
a like if you enjoy watching boys hit
the sky girl birthday I'll see you
tomorrow I'll be res say awesome